I'm a long time iPhone user and the last
time I was intrigued enough to
personally buy a Samsung device was the
s7 edge but when the s10 devices were
announced like many of you I couldn't
resist
[Music]
now we obviously have a tech channel
here on YouTube so we were gonna pick
one up anyways but I wanted to give this
beautiful device a chance to win over a
permanent spot in my pocket it's been a
month now and I'll be honest yes I did
switch back to the iPhone 10s max I'll
let you know why soon but first let me
tell you everything I love about the SN
Plus and the things that really annoyed
me let me start out with the best thing
that no one is talking about the LTE
speeds I don't know if it's just my
network my city or what but wow what a
difference
I tested it around town and the sm+
routinely gets twice the LTE speed than
my 10s max and at least one extra Barbe
reception in tough areas this isn't just
in benchmarks but I noticed it every day
everything loads faster buffering is
minimized and I can reliably stream
1440p video where my iPhone would hang
up with 1080p if you're an iPhone user
struggling with reception this alone may
be a reason to switch the S 10 plus is
an amazing device and a big step ahead
of the pixel 3-1 plus 60 and other
androids comparing the hardware with
iPhone flagships it's definitely the
more impressive device samsung has made
some great strides over the s9 and note
9 I didn't think they could make the
display any better but they did battery
life was good now it's better they did
have a notch before and we still don't
the cut out is much less intrusive even
the pill-shaped one with SN plus when
you put this thing up to the iPhone it
looks like the future and it puts the
pixel 3 to shame
I do wish that it didn't have the depth
sensor and retain the s tens and that's
tiny circular cutout but that's a minor
complaint on the back we now have three
cameras and I love that we have a
wide-angle lens the quality is as good
as the main shooter but the perspective
it provides is very unique the
distortion is surprisingly minimal due
to software correction and for most
people even those who have actual
cameras this will be wider than other
lenses at they own I own seven cameras
and dozens of lenses but I used my phone
more often for photos because it's
always there so the camera quality
really matters to me this means that I
always try to own the best smartphone
camera available and through the years
that's been the iPhone switching to the
Samsung I wasn't giving up quality like
I was in the past in our own blind
comparison the sn+ beat out the iPhone
overall and watching zone of text X
comparison I chose the iPhone as my
preference but the sn+ was very close
there were three things that bug me
though first pin ramus are now shot
using the wide-angle lens this gives you
a different perspective but can really
mess up your images second for portraits
you now have to use the standard lens
and set at the telephoto now this is
great to show more of your scene and
helps in low-light but Samsung is the
king of giving us options why not let us
choose which lens is better for a
particular situation both for portraits
and panoramas the third is the shutter
lag Apple was able to fix this since
it's a 12 processor with our smart HDR
is constantly taking a bunch of images
which does introduce some more noise but
you never miss a shot the sand plus at
times can have close to a second of
delays so I didn't miss some shots of my
kids that I wouldn't have with iPhone as
far as video and my quality they have
also made some great strides but from my
pro videography perspective the overall
quality is still behind Apple this is a
microphone quality from the galaxy s 10
Plus this is a microphone quality of the
iPhone 10 s max stabilization is great
and the super smooth video is really
cool but it's limited to 1080p almost no
reviewers actually went into the HDR 10
plus recording feature and that's
because it's not really usable for most
if you want to actually edit and upload
your videos it's mostly only good if you
want to watch the videos on the phone
itself one video feature I missed is 24
frames per second recording on the
iPhone which helps in low-light and is
great if you want to match with other
camera footage speakers have always been
the weak point for Samsung but not
anymore the stem plus doesn't sound as
good as the iPhone and yes I did enable
Dobey ammos but it's closed and much
louder
[Music]
honestly I would choose the s10 speakers
any day since the extra volume comes in
really handy when listening to a podcast
or video that's too quiet speaking of
watching videos oh man the experience is
fantastic not only is the HDR both
brighter and more contrast II but the
high-res display with the ability of
stream 1440p instead of 1080 really
makes the image pop not only that but
the small cutout is way less noticeable
and since its offset I can flip the
phone and so it's at the bottom right
next to my palm and I notice it even
less that better video viewing
experience also drains more of the
battery but since the sm+ has a larger
battery i still get about 30 minutes to
an hour more screen on time than the
iPhone now let's touch on the ultrasonic
fingerprint reader the tech is super
cool and we couldn't fully in our
fingerprint hacking video but actually
using it was a hit or miss I tried
different pressures angles lengths to
leave my finger on it and it just wasn't
consistent I then thought to try to
register the same fingerprint again and
it worked much better the next day Lou
put out a video on this and I was glad
that it wasn't just me I added a third
print and it got even better it's still
not perfect but better than before
I think Samsung can tweak this over time
and I know the text will improve in the
future but for now it's definitely not
as easy of space ID there's one thing
that I don't love about the SN plus an
actual day to day use and that's the
curved edges yes it looks great for
product shots and makes the phone
slimmer so it's more comfortable to use
in the hand but I would often
accidentally change YouTube videos and
randomly like Instagram photos
personally I prefer the standard flat
design of the s10 II and I would take
that if they offered it with this larger
size so we talked a lot about hardware
now let's touch on the software the new
one UI is an improvement from the past
but Samsung still has a way to go with
speed and reliability compared to one
plus I ended up changing my icons on the
keyboard when everything from my 1 plus
60 is great out of the box and that
ability to customize everything is the
beauty of Android wear iOS is more
lockdown but on another hand iOS does
have a lot fewer app crashes glitches
and bloatware notifications on the S 10
were annoying with games trying to get
me to play apps wanting to be downloaded
and Amazon wanting me to shop all of
this can be customized and fixed but
with the iPhone you don't have to now on
the plus side I'm always surprised by
the extra features I notice in apps that
I use most often
I love Facebook's messenger
little pop-up overlay and YouTube's
picture-in-picture mode so it's all of
the great hardware features and
improvements of the s10 over the iPhone
why did I end up switching back it's
basically the whole Apple ecosystem
holding me in if it wasn't I would
switch but I left my Apple watch and
also having continuity with my max I use
airdrop almost daily and forced touch
really speeds things up for me along
with that I didn't realize how much
losing iMessage would actually affect me
Apple is great I'm making the products
work seamlessly which is nice but it
also sucks because it locks you in if I
didn't need Mac OS every day for work
and I didn't own and love the Apple
watch I would have not switched back to
the iPhone Destin plus is in my opinion
the best phone on the market it's not
perfect but it's the closest thing you
can get to it if you're an iPhone user
that's not too locked in and thinking of
switching do it and if you're using
Android already and one upgrade it's a
no-brainer
thanks for watching if you want to see
more videos like this one including our
galaxy SN II review click that little
circle above to subscribe and check out
our other SN videos including these ones
this man max max tech and I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]